hi there steve kaufman here i'm going to
follow up with another video
i received a
a comment
from a miss soul
who is a canadian who's studying korean
and other languages from what i can
gather from looking at her youtube
channel and who has lived in the u.s
and she sent me a list of questions
which she wants me to answer in a video
and i'm going to do that i don't
normally do this sort of thing but i
checked out her channel and she seemed
like a very interesting person
and if you go to her uh youtube channel
which i'll put in the explanation
uh you'll see that she did one on
discrimination now miss seoul i don't
know what her real name is is black and
she had an experience first of all she
had she experienced some racial
discrimination
uh from koreans via you know in response
to one of her videos
and then she had an experience in
kentucky where she went to party and she
was um you know met with a certain
degree of hostility and that this
hostility eventually
melted at least in so far some of the
people are concerned and she talks a
little bit about discrimination and she
has a very open mind on this subject
which i found
very
enlightened
and certainly the experience as she
points out racial discrimination is not
the preserve of any race
and the uh the scenario that she
describes at this party where she was a
lone black person amongst a bunch of
somewhat hostile white people
could easily have been reproduced if she
were the lone white person in a party
where they were all black people
or asians or you know
protestant irish and catholic irish you
name it
uh the propensity for human beings to
develop irrational dislikes of people
who support different soccer teams or
whatever
uh is uh you know has been with us for a
long time and it's not about to go away
and it's no one's special preserve so
but because of that video which i found
very interesting and i recommend i am
going to answer her questions now i have
to go find those questions
and i will continue all right so the
first question is what do you consider
to be your native language english what
was your first language learning
experience in my case it's a little
complicated because i was born in sweden
and at the age of five my family moved
to canada so i learned my first
language english
other than the language that i was born
with
but i have no recollection of doing so
so i arrived in canada at the age of
five and all i can remember is speaking
english with my friends soon i had
forgotten swedish and everything
happened in english
but the first language that i
deliberately learned
i guess would be french which i had at
school and didn't speak and then i went
to university and had a very stimulating
professor of french civilization who
turned me on to french and as a
consequence turned me on to language
learning what languages have you studied
and why did you start them well the next
language was chinese i was sent to hong
kong to learn
mandarin by the canadian government i
was a canadian government trade
commissioner canada was about to
recognize the people's republic of china
so i went there and learned chinese
thereafter i went to japan and studied
well lived there and learned japanese
essentially on my own while living there
and thereafter i mean there's a whole
number of languages
that i went after and um i think i've
detailed that elsewhere but it adds up
to 12 and i'm working on my 13th which
is korean
uh
in the last five years i've learned
cantonese russian czech portuguese and
if i get the korean down it'll be five
since the age of 55.
the last 12 years how does your
personality affect how you learn
languages
uh
i think
yeah if you're uh serious and motivated
and interested in different peoples
different cultures different histories
at least i am and that is a large part
of my motivation for learning languages
i think personality wise i'm not afraid
to speak and make mistakes and i think
that helps me
i'm confident that i can learn these
languages so that helps me
next question do you prefer learning
languages in a class or individually
not even close i don't like going to
class i only learn individually
six what are your favorite language
learning materials
well
when we start we have to i use beginner
stuff
but as soon as possible i try to get
into things that interest me which is
very often history politics things of
that nature and then somewhat later
literature
how much time do you spend actively
learning per day
i would think about an hour a day and if
i get motivated on a weekend it can
become two or three hours
next question what are your short-term
and long-term language learning goals
my short-term goal is to develop enough
knowledge of korean
largely through my passive listening and
reading and some talking
so that
in six months from now i can go to korea
spend a couple of weeks and really
convert that passive knowledge into
something approaching fluency in korean
a longer term goal is i want to find the
time to get back at the languages that i
have already learned including the most
recent ones russian jack portuguese and
so forth and even some of my old
favorites like chinese and japanese and
improve in all of them and the way i
improve is listening and reading and of
course using link to increase my
vocabulary
what is your favorite language
um i guess my favorite language is very
often the one that i just left like
right now it's very difficult for me to
leave check and do korean when i was
starting in the czech i found it very
difficult to leave russian to get into
korea so i tend to get very much
committed to the language that i'm
learning
ten what is the next language you want
to learn
i don't know the more languages i learn
the more difficult it is to find the
time to enjoy them all but i guess
arabic would be high on the list arabic
turkish because i know so little about
the middle east and central asia in that
area
what advice can you give new language
learners
enjoy enjoy the process so that you put
in enough time that would be one
do things that you enjoy doing
and second of all be independent
therefore
seek out
content lessons material that is of
interest to you
and when you are learning
learn to notice what's happening in the
language seek things out in the language
not only words but patterns
you have to take the initiative to
discover the language
so there you have it miss seoul
thank you for contacting me i can tell
you if i hadn't gone to your
channel and uh if i hadn't seen that
nice video that you did on the subject
of racial discrimination and how open
and
balanced you are i probably wouldn't
have done this
uh so there we have it now let's uh so
i'll close this out now so yeah thank
you for listening bye for now